Good afternoon guys! Here in
McAllen, Texas. We have Raul and
we have Brian. They're going
to bring us into the details on
how migrants navigate
the United States once they get
over that wall, once they get on
US soil. What exactly happens?
Raul lives here in McAllen,
knows.. it's almost the
migrant path right? They go
point A to point B, to point C,
Point D and out? While they're
being processed until they get
shipped out where they're going
to get shipped out to.
So what's the first step,
you know, they get over the border..
Basically they cross the river,
come over the border wall
or around the border wall, just
depending. And then once
they get apprehended, which
they want to get apprehended,
because they know they're going
to be released, they get
apprehended by Border Patrol.
They get brought into the
holding facility over here in
Donna Texas. From that
Donna facility they get
processed and whatever they're
going to do. That's a
massive facility, right? It's a
huge facility right now.
It's close to 5000 people in
that facility. Okay. So once
they get processed in that
facility, they're brought to
McAllen to what I call is Tent
City - that's where they do
the COVID testing and stuff.
After the COVID testing, if
they're negative, they go a
little bit further down a few
blocks over to the Catholic
charity. This is the
COVID testing you're talking
about? Yes. Right, so just to be
straight: they come over, they
put their hands up or
whatever, and the Border
Border Patrol says: “Okay,
you're coming with us”. Yes. They
go on a bus, they go to the big
facility for how many days? The
Donna facility it’s about 3
day process. Okay. But
depending: right now, they're a
little bit backtracked due to
the amount of people they have
in there, but normally
it's like a three-day process.
Okay, and then they don't know
if they have COVID, then or not
right? They get tested after
that 3 day process?
After they're done from there, they
ship them over here, where they
get tested over here. And this
is over here. This is in
McAllen, Texas. The next step:
so they come into
this facility to get tested. Now,
if they're if they're positive,
what happens? If they're
positive, they get
shipped to San Juan or to some
some of the hotels that are
being paid for by the
government. Okay.
So they're funding hotels
for them, that way they can go
ahead and stay there in
quarantine in a hotel room,
with no supervision or
anything, so nothing to stop
them from leaving that hotel.
Okay. So in the hotel how many
days? As far as I know they're
renting it for 7 days for them.
And then after the 7
days, what happens exactly?
They find out where their
families are or whatever they're
going to do. They'll give them
bus tickets, they'll give them
a packet with the information
from the government, saying
they're allowed to roam
freely throughout the United
States. Some are giving their
court dates, some are not.
The reason why I’m saying that some
are not, they're holding back that
process to speed up stuff.
Okay, what if they come in here
and are negative? If they're
negative, they're
going to come down south about
two blocks over. We're going to
go there right? Yes. Okay.
We're on our way that way right now.
Sorry, if they're negative, they go
directly to the Catholic charity? Yes.
Everyone? Yes. Okay. I gotta
say this is very hard
content to make, because it's
such a it's such a polarising,
complex, difficult issue.
I remember when I was in my
younger 20s, I was living in
Durango, Colorado, and there's
this family in the entryway
of a grocery store.
And they obviously didn't know
what they're doing or where
they're going. And I put them
up in a hotel for a week.
I didn't know their story
or anything other than I was a
human, and I wanted to help. So I
see the humanitarian side of it
and then I see a system
of laws, and people that have
tried to immigrate for many
years legally into the country
and why should someone be able
to just come in? If you open the
borders completely, you'd have
millions and millions and
millions of people from all
over the world coming, because
that's just how the world
works: people go where the
opportunities are. It's always
worked, and it always will
work that way. I'm not giving
you a clear answer and
I don't want to, to be honest.
It would be easier just to give
you “it's black and white”, and
that's not fair, and it's not
honest. Of course, I have my
bias, from my experiences in
life living overseas and
traveling a lot of the world.
The thing I come back to and I
love about the US is how things
work, and how there's law. Most
are coming (I don't know all
their stories, I want to talk
to a migrant, it’s really
freaking hard, I don't think
it's going to happen), but most
of the stories are, you know,
people running from bad
situations obviously, and I'm
sure there are all
sorts of stories like cartels,
human trafficking. These things
are all happening at once, so I
could show a story of a kid
that's in down and out, and
that's a true story, and I can
show the cartel member, who's
benefiting off the Border
Patrol not being able to really
do much these days, having their
hands tied, being overwhelmed,
and that's a true story too.
So yeah, the first step is
not testing, the first step is
just getting in a holding
facility, right? Right.
These tests
basically tell, if they had it
before when they came over,
but they go into a
facility crowded together with
a bunch of people for 3 days,
and they come out and get
tested as the test will catch,
if they were already positive.
But then the people that
test negative could be could be
holding the virus, it just
hasn't shown up yet, and
they let them go, and then they
can test positive later, but
they're never going to be
tested again. Okay. How long is
this been going on for, Raul,
this set up? As we see here?
This tent city right here just
started after the McAllen bus
station. It came out that they
transported 150 people that
were COVID positive, so right
after that, they made a big
deal about the bus station,
so they made it mandatory
that they get slips, saying
they are COVID negative
before they're allowed
into their buses. So this is
the Charity? Yes, and that's one
of the white vans waiting to
transport people from here to
the airport. Okay,
so if they're COVID
negative: into the charity, and
then in a van out to the
airport or to the bus station?
Well, the bus stations right here,
so those in a van will be going
to the airport. And then
where are they going?
Wherever their
destination is, whether it's
California, New York, Chicago.
They get to choose? They get to
choose. So basically they're
saying: “I have family
in New York”, and they
look up their family and they
give them a call and whatever
and coordinate whatever
they're going to coordinate .
They provide ICE the name
and address of somebody in the
US and they buy either a bus
ticket or a plane ticket. Most
of them from McAllen are going
directly to DFW, and that's
where they're spreading out
from there. Okay, so they can
choose wherever they want to
go. What if someone doesn't
have a connection? Let's go
across the street. Well, that's
what I heard about 3 days ago,
and that's what we need to
check into. There's this one
girl who said: “The
Catholic Church found my family
in California”, but when
when my people asked her: “Do you
have people in California?”,
she's like: “I don't know!” Okay,
and so we ask her: “How do you
know that you're going to
actually go to your family?” and
she's like: “They talk to him,
they arranged that they
gave me my ticket. I'm going to
California”. She doesn't know
where she's going, she doesn't
know who, she doesn't know
nothing! All she knows is the
Catholic charity found her
family and they're on
the way. But yet she
never spoke to that family at
all, so who knows where she's
actually going. I used to
actually stay here at the
Catholic Charities. One day,
hen it was really f***ing cold out,
they decided to say “**** y'all,
because y’all like to smoke, and
y'all like to drink, and we
don't like that”. But yet they
have an employee, that's
sitting there bit**ing, that we need
to make America Mexican again,
and he's sitting there smoking
pot. Alright. So you you were
you were in this, you were
staying in this charity and
they said you had to leave? Yes.
But you were smoking and
doing s**t, right? Yeah, but I wasn't
smoking in there. Okay. I was
following all the rules, they
told me, if I come in and I
look high, I can't stay. About
how many people did they kick
out besides you? In total, I'd
say they kicked out roughly
sixty to seventy homeless
people. And they're all American
citizens as far as you know?
As far as I know, they're
all American citizens. There's
even an older gentleman, who's
missing a leg, who's in a
wheelchair, and they kicked him
out to the streets. And did they
give you a reason why they
kicked you all out? They said
it was because of our drug
habits. I'm like: “So what, we
have drug habits, you don't
know what's going on in our
lives, that makes us choose
drugs. Just let it stay here”.
Do you want to get off drugs?
Yeah! You do? If someone
who came through it and
was like: “We're going to help
you get off drugs. Would you be
down or you'd be like **** that?
I'd be down. Really? What are you on?
What's your go to?
I’m on spice. What's that? I don't know
what that is. Fake marijuana.
No, but it's worse than
marijuana. Yeah. What do you
mean? It's a synthetic weed.
So what happens - all the
chemicals in there get you
hooked on it like that. Oh..
That's what happens to all the
little smoke shops they used to
sell that stuff. I don't know
if they still do, but yeah,
they used to sell that stuff
They do.
The thing that I said,
it's more.. with all the
different chemicals in there..
sometimes they'll kill
you right off the bat or it's
highly addictive. Yes, they can
Put fentanyl, opiates, heroin
whatever they want on it, they
even spray raid. Raid? Like the
bug repellent spray? They put
rat poison. They'll do
anything in it. It's more
profitable that way, huh?
Yeah, cheaper
chemicals. I was going to say,
it's more profitable to just
stick the camera out there, sneak an
interview, you never know. Or you
go in there. You should do it,
make a video. If I could get
into that b**ch, man, I would sit
there and I'd make them
actually question their
religion. Oh, no, they're
they're religion right
there is.. how
much you going to pay and
they'll change it, they'll
change their ways. Take care
man. Good luck, get off
that stuff.
Get off that stuff, that stuff's
going to kill you. Alright,
how are the people in the
community feeling, because an
interesting fact about being
here in McAllen for the last
few days is: if you don't talk
to a guy like you, I would have
no idea anything's going on the
streets. The streets are
normal, it’s not like you see
this chaos or anything on the
streets, the city
looks normal. Basically
everything functions as normal.
Like you said, if you
don't see it directly,
you'll never know, that it's
happening. And that's why
we need to get
people to know that
there is a problem. Like I
said, it doesn't only affect
McAllen, the county of Hidalgo
or the state of Texas. Right.
It affects everybody in general,
because these people get sent
all over the United States and
somehow or another taxpayers
are paying for that, whether
it's their tickets, their
shelter, like the the hotels
that they're putting up for them.
And once they get here, then the
church is covering their
initial expenses at least, right?
Exactly. And who's giving
the church the money to do it?
The government does. Ahh.. I'm sorry
to say it, but the church sold
themselves, and it's not the
first time, but they've sold
themselves because it's a money
maker.
Alright guys. I'm here with my
good buddy and former
immigration lawyer friend
Rafael Mariano, and Rafael has
brought me through some of the
basics here, which I had no
clue about. I think most people
don't have any clue about
unless they've been in, you
know, what you've done to
understand the process. So Rafa,
walk us through the legal
process. If someone comes over
through a port of entry and
they're, you know, they get
into the United States legally
like you did, there's a very
clear legal process, that they
take, right? Correct. But if
somebody goes through a non
port of entry like crosses the
river, gets apprehended by
border patrol, a lot of them
are not getting sent back, it’s
hard to know the exact number,
but I saw it with my own eyes,
and then if you look at the
customs and Border protection,
the numbers are way up. Correct
So they're seeking
asylum. Correct. And that means
they're not legal in the United
States or they're illegal until
their court hearing? Or walk
us through how that works. So
this is another complicated
process, right, this is the
asylum process. So what
that means is if you're seeking
asylum, you can try to
cross and you say..
basically you’re intentionally
caught. Say: hey, look,
I’m here, I’m seeking
asylum. Okay. To do
that you're going to have to
prove, that you're a refugee,
that your situation fits on
the refugee status and
requirements. Of course, there’s
an officer there, you're not going
to need to prove to him.
You can’t, that's law, that’s
not the due process.
You're going to say: look, I’m
here to seek asylum right, so
take me and usually.. you
know, I believe what's happening
now, supposedly, I don't know.
So what used to happen is: you get
caught, you're processed,
and you're sent
your way right.
Why that happens, because you
cannot seek asylum while you
are still in your country,
that's not how the
process works. You only
can seek asylum, of course
there are exceptions and I
don't have a year here for me
to go through everything,
right? Yeah, give us
the quick play by
play points let's say. Because
in all the research I've
done the further you get down
this rabbit hole, it’s just
rabbit hole after rabbit hole,
and you can go in and like.. it's
a full lifetime. Yeah, it's
huge. So you're here, presenting
yourself, I’m a refugee.
I'm seeking asylum, you’re processed
or whatever, you're seeing
your way inside of the US. You
have a court date.
So you're not legal at all,
you are asylum seeker.
But until your court
date, you have papers saying
you're legal to be in the
United States. Yes, I believe
if they give you yes, because
you're going to be processed
you're going to have a
paperwork explaining a
situation. We have a court date.
Okay. The court date is
not a legalisation day.
It's really a court day for
you to be there and prove, that
you are in fact a refugee, and
it's a really hard burden
you have to prove, because
you're alleging that you're a
refugee seeking asylum.
So you stand in front of
the judge at the court? You
have to have evidence
obviously, and then what
percentage of these people
seeking asylum, you know, what
percentage get denied? So
can I just really quickly tell
you what you need to prove?
Because that's important
because it's hard. So you
need to prove that you're a
refugee, so to do that you have
to fulfil some requirements.
What are the requirements: you
have to prove that you are
being persecuted in our
country, and you are
being persecuted because
specifically those factors:
because of race, because of
religion, because of your nationality,
because of your political opinion
or because you belong to this
specific social group suffering
discrimination or prosecution
in your own country, and it's
hard. You need to have
witnesses, documents showing
that, so because of that, this
is average, I’m just
telling you like a total number,
a total percentage of asylum
applications that are denied.
It varies between 65 to 70%.
So it’s high, so
basically we think among ten
applicants approximately only
three are approved, can prove
their case. The migrants
that come over, that
spend all the money to the
cartels and the coyotes, and the
smugglers and all that to get
over. They're spending all
their money and then.. there's no
guarantee, once they sort
of have a little window getting
into the US, where they're like,
okay, we can breathe and relax
now we're legal here, legal
until a court hearing?
Protected yes. But then by
going to the hearing, the
probability that
you're going to get sent back
home is high? Super high. Alright.
So how long.. and this is a
really difficult part about
this. I want to explain to the
audience here, guys. You know,
the more I research and
this is rabbit hole after
rabbit hole, there's one
website and everything is
politicised with this topic,
there's no way around that,
except this one site I found
“track immigration” - who knows but
from what I saw, they say
they're independent and
nonpartisan, but that's the
website. I also want to aim
people towards like.. we're
touching the basics here and we
have to keep it short for a
YouTube video, but if you
want to get in, I find the
metrics really break down. So
the people that say 99% of
migrants go back to their court
hearing: when you start breaking
apart those numbers, you
realise, well, these are case
studies specific areas, we’re
not talking as like a national
whole. And then the
people that say 99% avoid their
asylum hearings, I don't think
those are correct numbers
either. So it's really hard in
itself just to get the right
numbers, because the immigration
court records are secret. Also,
this is what I read: so the
statistics are difficult to
verify in this, but just from a
common sense level I would
think: alright, I made all that
effort, I spend all that money,
and if I go to court and the
the probabilities I'm going to
get sent home - probably wouldn't
want to go. But I don't want to
aim that argument,
what do you think on that?
So from my.. look,
saw a lot of people who are
seeking asylum and that's
the difference: the
immigrants that are really here
as a refugees, they will attend
the court, because they have a
valid case, and they fear if
they're going to go back to
their country, they're going to
get killed, or sent to jail
forever, or will disappear.
So I do not know the numbers,
like you said, it’s very hard
to find the real statistic, how
many of those people that enter
here, then attend the hearing -
I don't know. What I know is the
law is clear: if you're here as
a refugee seeking asylum for a
year or more, you can never
again go to the court and make
sure you have the asylum
status. That's it. You have 1
year inside of the US to fix
your situation. What if the
courts are backed up like right now,
because I read there are 400
asylum judges and they're
just backed up
and especially with this recent
surge, like the processing is
probably falling behind I can
imagine.. Well but that's
not their fault, right?
If we will start that
process right within the year,
it's just that the court date
may not be within a year or
sometimes is within a year, but
that is continued because of
that. But that's not their
fault, right? Right. What's going
on is - if you enter and then you
wait, maybe you miss your court,
or maybe you don't do anything
for a year, and then you say:
Hey, I'm going to do
my  process,
make sure I am a refugee
legally”. If you passed that
year, that's it, you'll be
deported. And I just really
want to make clear to you guys.
You know, getting into this
whole border situation. I'm
almost embarrassed as an
American didn't know.. I didn't
really know anything about it until
recently, I didn't start
putting any attention towards
it, until I went there and.. What
you realise is that: I thought,
and I was told too a few times,
that if someone
got in seeking asylum, then
they're legal to be in the US,
but no, you're telling us no -
it’s just a window of time and
then they can either take a
decision to go to that court
hearing or disappear in the
society and be illegal.
Correct. And that's the
thing: if you missed your court
hearing, from the bench the
judge will issue a deportation
order for you. And then if you get
caught, if they find you - that's
it: you'll be deported, and then
as I explained before, when
you're deported, you're not
going to be able to come back
here even if you have a visa.
There is a certain thing that
I'm going to say, because a lot
of people don't know that: if
you enter here illegally,
without inspection,
and then you live your
life, you work, you meet a
American citizen and you get
married, and you think wow! Now I
will be able to legalise my
status and be able
to become a resident, and then a
citizen.. If you're married to an
American, you're in or
should be, right? Yes, but!
A lot of people think that
that's the goal: they're going
to find American citizens, marry
and everything's good, and that’s
not true. If you enter illegally
without inspection, without a
visa, even if you marry an
American citizen, as soon as you
start your process, while your
mitigation process, when your
petition is approved, you will
be deported back to your
country, and if you’re
in the country for over
180 days illegally, you will be
sent back to your country with
a mandatory ban to enter again
for 10 or 20 years.
That's if you marry
an American. Even if you
marry an American, you're going
to go back, you're going
to have to do a consular process
in your own country, but as a
punishment, because you
committed a crime, right,
you're going to be there for
10-20 years, and then your
petition may be approved, but
look, more likely than not -
you're done. Once you're out,
they're not going
to allow you
back, and do you think
your marriage will survive
10-20 years? Your wife living in
the US and you're living
outside of the country? Right.
I mean, that's the
reality that nobody really
knows. As you can see
guys, it's the the deeper
you go in.. and Rafa told me:
what, do you want like a week to
talk about this to
understand it? And I said no,
this is a short synopsis.
So, that’s so
complex, right?
What are your thoughts?
Like to close this up
here, and there's no simple
solution, there's no.. magic
cure. But what do you
say, what would be the right way
to do it? I don't think
anyone knows this. Look, we have
good laws in the US. We do have
laws, but the problem is,
you know, we have the problem of
enforcement of those laws. We
have the problem of controlling
the border. So really the
problem is manpower in courts
processing your immigration
paperwork and on the border,
and I really don't know if we
as a country, we have appetite
to spend that kind of money
resource to fix that issue,
I really don't know. I don't see
a clear solution.
What about the migrants,
I was told, you know, migrants
when they come into the States,
what I saw firsthand
where they were given issued
plane tickets the Catholic
Charity was funding, their stay
and food and clothes, stuff like
that. Now when they're
going all over the country
right now, it's not like
they're staying in McAllen,
Texas or these border cities,
like they're getting
distributed, you can go on the
planes, right, you go on a plane from
McAllen to Dallas, and
migrants are there with little
pamphlets, saying they don't
speak English, and they're
given other documents.. What's
happening now is also not
helping the asylum seekers.
It's just for show! Because
those people the best case
scenario, you know, 70% is
going to be denied.
You're saying like the
what's going on now is not
helping the asylum seekers?
I mean it's helping right now.
I mean for this..
immediately, it's helping them,
because they are not in their
country, right? That's helpful -
they are here. But long term -
I don't think it's going to help
them, because they're going to
have to go through the process.
So if they show up in court and
they can’t prove their case as a
refugee, they're going to be
deported, and that's it. And
you know per the statistics
only three out of ten is going
to be legit, they're going to
be able to prove their case.
Right. You know, and all the
rest are going to be departed.
They're screwed. Then they're
never going to be.. Unless
there's a change in the law,
like amnesty is granted. Yes,
unless that's the plan, that they
are saying, look, we're going to
let, whatever is the number, a
million people get in, and then
as soon as we reach that number,
we’re going to sign the amnesty
regarding everybody that is
here, as long as you
never committed a crime.
Also, you
have that. There are a lot of
government resources federal
resources, and I think state
resources probably, going
towards these people, that
might get sent back most likely,
if they go to court. Yeah.
I was told food stamps, but I
think that's a federal thing, I
think you have to be a US
citizen for food stamps, but
how much do you think is being
spent, and you don't have to
have a number, but as far as
what you saw with the people,
your clients that you were
representing? How much was the
system paying for their lives
here in the US? So that's
the thing I'm not
really sure what's happening
right now inside of the system.
When I was representing
immigration clients, they
they were receiving zero
assistance from the US
government. There was no
assistance,
no plane tickets or bus
tickets. You are processed, and
you are let go, and then you
just have to obtain your court
hearing, but at that time, they
are not controlling where you go.
Because if you're
not a US citizen and
you don't really qualify for
any government assistant.
I am an immigrant, I was
never a illegal immigrant,
I am a US citizen now.
But when I was a only a US
resident, what that means is
when you have a green card,
I would never qualify for any
government assistance. I was
was paying taxes, but I would
not qualify for, you know,
social security, or any
government grant, or anything.
So I'm not sure what's
happening now. So I know now
they've at least from what I
saw in McAllen, they're
getting plane tickets, bus
tickets, and I was rumoured
a card with a certain amount of
money on it (800 to 1200), but I
can't verify that, money to
spend once getting
over, because these people are
coming over with like nothing
by the time for sure. By that
point, they spent so much money
to get over, I don't think
they're coming with much, but
also something.. and this could
actually turn into a freaking
podcast, because there's so much
to talk about. But they're not
legal, so if they're here for a
year, these migrants and
they're not legal,
like until their court hearing
and that goes through the system
then how are they making money?
You know, they're going to have
to work illegally, right? Isn't
that the only way you're going
to make money? Yeah,
it is. I mean if you're here in
this limbo status, and
you don't have a social
security, you don't have a work
permit or anything, you cannot
legally work. You can’t. You're
going to have to work
illegally, which is also
a crime. And then when you start
your immigration process,
you're going to be punished by
it too. It's going to be a
financial fee the US
government will apply to you
and you have to pay. What
do they expect, how
are people supposed to live a
year without working and making
money? Exactly! That's what I'm
saying: the solution is tricky
because nobody wants to
resolve that for sure why,
because those people, and I know
because I have a lot of clients,
like they are working, they are
working illegally, but a lot of
people don't talk about that:
they are also paying taxes.
Yes, because usually they are
using a different name or a
fake social security number, so
the US government it is
collecting taxes and those
taxpayers are not collecting
their refund. Right! Wo then
it's a free money for the US
government. It’s cyclical.
How crazy is that that the system
with social security numbers
isn't set up correctly where
someone can get a social
security number, who is not a
citizen or not legal here, and
then out of their pay-check
money goes towards the federal
government, and the federal
government takes it in, the
worker gets none of the
tax back or, you know, none
of the rebates at the end of
the year or anything. Correct.
And then everyone just pretends or
what, what's going on there?
Correct, everybody pretends and
it's a free.. Basically, I know
the US is spending a lot of money
with the processing, and you
know.. managing those
prisons, and the airplanes, and
all, but also they.. It's
just my little observation,
but what the US gain: very
cheap labor and basically
gain free tax money, that nobody
will ever ask for a refund.
You know, and I don't know what
are those numbers that would be
a very good area to research as
well: how much we are really
making with that and how
much we are spending.
Alright, you want
to close on anything Rafam
anything else you want to say
here? No, I'm just saying that
I really feel bad
for for all those people,
that are legitimately
coming here and trying to improve
their lives and risking
their lives, and I
really I don't know what is the
solution that we work for
everybody. I feel bad for all
parties involved. I feel bad
for Customs and Border Patrol
calling themselves the babysitters
now because they're taking care
of kids and can't do their job.
I feel bad for the migrants
coming from bad situations.
I feel bad the overall situation,
that we are incentivising
criminality, you know, with
bad actors doing, you know,
because customs is so burdened,
there's the
opportunity now, human
trafficking, drug trafficking,
all this stuff and a lot of
people talk about the ICE
agents. The officers
there that are risking
their lives too. Some of them
get killed! It's not easy
work out there. Not easy.
Don't worry, I'm sure our
politicians will fix this in
the next couple of years,
because they do care about all
of our best interests.
For sure! Don’t worry, we're all set.
Alright, Rafa, thank you.
Oh, and for the closing I want to
say to the audience here: Rafa
is the the quintessential
American dream. He was a soap..
actually, it's a little
different one: he was a soap
opera star actor in Brazil,
then had to basically hit the
floor cleaning hotel rooms in
Reno, Nevada. It's true! Your
first job, and the Mexican
cleaners that were with him
were starstruck because they
couldn't believe their favourite
actor was cleaning alongside
them. That's true. And
then he worked up and now he
has his own law firm. So it's a
beautiful story. Thank you,
my friend. Thank you for being
part of this and explaining a
little more behind the scenes.
Thank you for being my friend
man. So I just want to mention
guys you don't just you just
don't show up in McAllen, Texas
and get into the scenes
with the camera. I'm only doing
so because I'm lucky enough
the United Cajun Navy reached
out to me, both Raul and Brian
are part of the organisation.
I want to make a distinction:
United, because there are many
Cajun Navies, this is the
United Cajun Navy, and you guys
basically do disaster relief,
hurricanes, tornadoes.
Most people know us as like
search and rescues, because
that's what they've seen
on the news, flood water
rescues, things like that.
But we've become more of a
logistical organisation. We
have warehouses back in
Louisiana, people donate a lot
of supplies and a lot of
a lot of different things, and
we just basically partner
with people who have trucks and
and they come pick it up and
take it out to areas, where
it's needed, and, you know, we
were reached out to saying that
there were supplies needed here
on the border, and we weren't
really sure what was going on
or why it was needed. We were
just told it was a humanitarian
crisis. So last month, I came
down myself and hooked up with
Raul to see what was going on,
and you know we see the
pictures of the kids sleeping
under tinfoil blankets, and we
have a lot of blankets that
were donated by American
Airlines for the recent freeze
over the winter, and so we're
like, okay, who can we send
supplies to, who can distribute
it for us? Thanks for bringing
me in and especially Raul iving here
and educating me on what's
going on the ground. That's
what you're doing. I’m
trying. We need to get this out
there and let everybody know
that it is a
problem, and it is going to
affect everybody in the long
run. Gotcha. Alright, until the
next video.